I thought I'd do an additional part on
this just gonna cover a few more
advanced tips so I'm just on I'm just a
new startup even if you go file new
general Halley there's file new video
editing does this go straight to it yeah
okay well if you're just on the opening
one it's it's also up here and you can
cut a video editing but yeah I didn't
know about that file a new video and
that's cool okay and you're taken to
this screen you can mouse wheel out on
here one of the first things you want to
do is set up your properties and make
sure all those look good
mainly your output going to where you
want to go I like to go to a folder
named rendered or save everything on a
second hard drive that way it doesn't
interfere with my OS drive while it's
rendering so much and file format ffmpeg
video is what I generally use and the
encoding here on the output generally
set the audio to AAC that seems to be
very reliable output quality previously
I said I always use medium that's not
completely true I mean if you bump it up
the render takes a lot longer but if
it's a final render you probably do want
to do this at least up to perceptually
lossless that should be enough there
I'll adjust the frames once I have my
video in the frame rate should come in
automatically let me grab a small video
from somewhere so bear with me just a
moment here here's a five a six kilobyte
video I don't even know what this is
looks like a some kind of legal legends
clip yeah alright so first thing I'm
gonna do while I'm down here guys I'm
gonna hit page up and then set this in
point to 771 that way I have the length
of the video as the render time and this
little number up here I think on my last
video I was on a beta version so it
appears have changed since then a little
bit what this is up here the first
number is the seconds and the second
number is the frame so since I'm at 30
frames per second usually I record
sixty but apparently I did this one a
thirty it'll be zero all the way up to
the frame thirty and then to one second
one of the big things I wanted to show
you is just how to do some work on this
this video because sometimes you'll take
like maybe your bring it in a cell phone
video and it's vertical and you don't
want it to be and you can change that by
well you click on your video so if you
click on it press shift a it'll bring up
this little menu and you can you can go
to effects strip and then transform and
you get a transform so now you can edit
this Green transform bar and it is
basically a transformation of this video
so if you change the length of this
video the transformation changes along
with it you want to click on this
transform and you can you can do things
now Larian effects like if I do another
transform on this transform things are
gonna get awkward so I wouldn't
recommend doing that if you want to do
multiple transforms you probably want to
render your first transform and then
bring in whatever you just rendered it
and then do a new new one on top of that
because layering transforms and my
experience gets a little weird and
doesn't always do what you expect so now
I've got this transform clicked I want
to show you how to just rotate it if you
look down here and effect strip you'll
see position scale and rotation so you
can adjust this rotation to just rotate
your video like so so you can do an
exact 90 degree rotation under Nady to
flip it etc and 360s back to where it
was and scale if you're doing scale you
can stretch out your video in either way
we set those back to 1 and position of
course just changes the position of it
now another thing that's really cool
about these is you can keyframe them in
I want to bring over a this is just part
of blender bring over a little second
thing
and change this second little area I'm
gonna change this to a dope sheet and
that's four keyframes so now that you
know how to flip your video sometimes I
mean sometimes you just want it to be
flipped the entire time but other times
you want it to kind of animate and you
don't this dope sheet is just a visual
representation of what I'm gonna show
you next here so say you want it to
start out normal and then right about
here you want to do something so what
you do is you go over the thing you want
to change like let's say the rotation
and you press I and that puts that marks
a point on that the timeline where stays
like that then you go to where you want
your change to be finished for what
you're doing and perform your change
let's say we want to do a just a full
rotation it's gonna be a little weird so
I'll do 360 or negative 360 and I'll
press I again so what's gonna happen in
between these two keyframes is it's the
video is gonna flip so check that out
and you can do that with anything you
can also do it with the volumes if your
what volumes to fade in and out and so
that's that's just something to keep in
mind to where you can do effects and you
can do fade ends by adjusting a
possitive pasady say you want to start
out a zero then about right here you
want it to be one so you change it to
one there press I now you notice you
start at the beginning when you play it
it'll look like it's fading it and you
can do the same thing with it going out
you don't have to do the opacity on a
transform you can do that on the true
video layer but if you've already got a
transform applied you might as well do
it on the transform so say for fade out
Oh
I marked it there then I'll go to the
end of the video change it to zero mark
it again by pressing I and there we go I
for insert keyframe so now I got a fade
and a little weird flip here and a
fade-out it's a lot of people like to
put their logos up and stuff and and
there's there's kind of multiple ways of
doing that if you just want to do it
with an image you literally just make an
image with whatever you want and then
you drag it in and let's see I'll just
use this old thumbnail from one of my
old old videos check it out so now I've
got this image in here and since it's
above the video it will be on top of it
like it'll just take up the space in the
video won't display wherever that is but
what you can do is you can move these
around you can press B to make a box
grab and grab all the stuff you want and
press G and then Y to lock to the y axis
and put those way up if you want you can
grab a little dot here on the edge to
make that wider and you can do the same
with the horizontal one too and that way
you can layer as you want see I'll put
it up here you see it put it down here
you don't see it cuz it's underneath but
maybe I don't know maybe I want it here
and you can also let me zoom back in
here and you can also adjust the length
of your videos however you want you can
do the same thing with her of your
images or I might say and do the same
thing with keyframes on those as far as
the opacity and you can mess around with
offsets and crops if you want and
there's also some additional facts with
the color again saturate multiply yeah
so that can be a kind of cool way to get
your images in there and get them fading
in as you want okay well I think that's
gone about do it for this episode and I
hope you found this handy and also one
last thing if you're bringing stuff and
you don't want it you can just
right-click it and go to delete
and remove it or just press the Delete
key
as far as cutting there's one more thing
I should probably tell you about cutting
I'm gonna go ahead and delete this
effect layer which gets rid of it all
the keyframes that were on it too so say
I want to cut this if I just hit plain
old kay it's a soft cut and with a soft
cut and bring these up a little bit you
can drag and restore your video of what
you cut there's also a hard cut which is
if you hold shift and hit K it does a
hard cut now a hard cut doesn't allow
you to restore video or audio so those
are the differences I'm not entirely I
always do soft cuts just because they're
easier to work with if you don't get
your cut perfect even fix it real easy
if you do a hard cut I think it saves
you a bit of memory but I've never
noticed a difference so that's that's
the final tip I got for you guys there
and you're ready to go just go up to
render and render animation and off it
goes
stop that alright thanks for watching
and I'll catch you guys in the next
video